Donald Glover’s music video for This is
America and tv show Atlanta, use similar methods
to make unique social commentary.
The director of the music video Hiro Murai,
is also a producer and frequent director on
the show, so let’s look at how this powerhouse
team uses Juxtaposition, Surrealism, Deadpan
Tone, and Symbolism in both the show and music
video to create some of the most artful social
commentary I’ve seen recently.
Juxtaposition
Both the show and the video, use the juxtaposition
of entertainment or humor against difficult
and violent realities.
In This is America the Juxtaposition is spacial
and temporal.
The focus remains on the dancing, while serious
problems manifest themselves in the background,
just out of our sight.
But the main character also shifts suddenly
between being the perpetrator and the entertainment.
This scene uses the juxtaposition of humor,
commercialism, and violence.
A joke that almost appears to be product placement,
is immediately followed by an image of violence,
and the whole scene is framed by the sound
of police sirens in the background.
Surrealism:
One of the tools used to create juxtaposition
in both works is Surrealism.
Take a look at this scene, which highlights
the sudden risk everyone in a house is put
under when the police are called about a domestic
dispute.
Even the two innocent bystanders in the house
are concerned about their safety when the
police show up.
But this reality is constantly in contrast
with the absurdist humor of
the scene.
By including surreal elements, the viewer
is forced to examine every part of the scene
from a fresh perspective, possibly causing
them to re-examine issues that had started
to seem normal.
This forces the viewer to come face to face
with the social issues that the creators want
to highlight.
As the music video’s central theme points
out, America has a focus problem.
Often ignoring the issues, or moving on from
them very quickly.
Because of this, embedding a social commentary
inside an entertaining song or show makes
it more likely to catch peoples attention.
Had Glover merely made a music video containing
the contents of the background, would people
be talking about it as much?
Deadpan Tone:
The juxtaposition and surrealism are emphasized
further by the deadpan delivery.
Within the music video and show, characters
often treat shocking or surreal events as
normal, barely reacting.
Sometimes characters on the show recognize
the absurdity of a situation but much is still
left unacknowledged.
In the music video, that role is left entirely
to the audience, by not acknowledging the
surreal or shocking elements, the viewer isn’t
told what to think or feel about them.
It provokes you to think about an issue, instead
of telling you what to think about it.
This deadpan tone is present in the visual
styles of both the show and the music video,
while the show is shot digitally and the music
video was show on film, Hiro Murai creates
a similar look for both.
Using high grain and noise profiles and coloring
to create a look often associated with “gritty
realism”.
Showing surrealist imagery through a look
associated with realism reinforces the juxtaposition
central to both works.
Symbolism:
The juxtaposition, surrealism and tone all
cause the viewer to look a little closer at
the works.
And when they do, they’ll find more there
to uncover.
Both use symbolism to guide the viewer in
thinking deeper and harder about the subject
matter.
Some of it is fairly accessible and apparent,
like the Jim Crow poses in the video, or the
fact that Atlanta’s protagonist is named
Earn, and the primary conflict for the character
revolves around earning a living.
Use of symbolism asks for and necessitates
a certain amount of interpretation.
The use of juxtaposition, surrealism, and
symbolism help form the social commentary,
but they make it difficult for viewers to
find a single clear message as part of the
works, instead opening them up for multiple
interpretations.
This isn’t a criticism, inability to find
a single straightforward message can cause
audience discomfort, but that’s reflective
of the discomforting complexities present
in the places these works are creating a portrait
of.
The video and show exist together as a body
of works that are illustrative of the places
who’s name they bear.
Forcing us to reexamine elements of those
places that have become normal to us, and
take a closer look at what surrounds us.